[Musique]
avec nous Eric la flèche président et
chef la direction du groupe métro
bonsoir Monsieur la flèche bonsoir
madame on va venir à cette question
poser au téléspectateurs dans un instant
mais d'abord vos résultats financiers
monsieur la flèche qui sont très
positifs qui ont été bien accueillis
dans quelle mesure l'inflation
explique-t-elle la hausse de votre
chiffre d'affaires on a eu des bons
résultats qu'on forme aux attentes il y
a une inflation alimentaire c'est clair
c'est mondial c'est un phénomène mondial
depuis plusieurs mois quelques
trimestres où l'accélération est un
forte hausse c'est un c'est un phénomène
mondial comme je l'ai dit qui duel à la
guerre en Ukraine le prix des intrants
les commodités le transport la
main-d'oeuvre les chaînes
d'approvisionnement très perturbées
alors on subit des augmentations de
coûtant de tous nos fournisseurs depuis
les derniers mois c'est une réalité
mondiale très difficile à accepter pour
tout le monde pour nos consommateurs
surtout et pour nous aussi parce que
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à gérer et
on n'est pas en mesure de passer dans
les prix de détails toute l'inflation
qu'on reçoit de nos fournisseurs
on a annoncé des bons résultats oui
l'inflation
contribue à la croissance de nos ventes
mais chacune de nos bannières tire son
épingle du jeu dans son marché pour la
question de l'effet de l'inflation sur
nos profits je vous dirais que nos
marges brutes donc la différence entre
le prix de vente et le prix payé pour
les marchandises notre marge de profil
brut est en déclin cette trimestre on le
dit depuis quelques mois que notre marge
brute sur les produits alimentaires est
en baisse c'était compréhensible par la
marge brute sur les produits
pharmaceutiques qui étaient en hausse
parce que la consommation de cosmétique
produit de beauté OTC est en hausse mais
ce trimestre aussi la marge globale est
en baisse et c'est encore une fois causé
par l'alimentation
vous vous comprimez les prix parce que
vous absorbez un parti des augmentations
de prix qu'on reçoit de nos fournisseurs
on n'est pas en mesure dans le marché
concurrentiel dans lequel on évolue on
n'est pas en mesure de tout d'augmenter
nos préventions de la même proportion
que les prix coûtant
si on comprend bien monsieur monsieur la
flèche à partir de février là à partir
de février ça fait trois mois qu'on a
refusé toute augmentation nos
fournisseurs comme il fait à chaque
année qu'il y a l'inflation ou pas
inflation on est très
occupé dans les fêtes c'est pas le temps
de négocier et de passer des heures en
magasin à changer des prix alors ça
c'est une pratique courante chez nous et
dans l'industrie en général de refuser
les augmentations des fournisseurs mais
le phénomène mondial de l'inflation
alimentaire se poursuit continue alors
il fonctionne nous ont indiqué que
d'autres augmentations à l'avenir après
notre période de jeûne et c'est ce qui
va se produire alors on négocie du mieux
qu'on peut on essaie de mitiger l'effet
de l'inflation le plus possible pour
avoir le moins d'impact possible sur nos
prix pour offrir la meilleure valeur
possible à tous nos clients dans
l'ensemble de nos bannières mais le
phénomène mondial les causes
sous-jacentes sont toujours là je pense
que tout le monde le comprend ça parce
que bon les consommateurs le voient
partout le voient eux-mêmes à la pompe
il y a toutes sortes d'éléments
effectivement qui nous touchent depuis
la guerre en Ukraine dans la dernière
année sauf évidemment pour un ménage
dont les revenus sont limités et on fait
face tous à une inflation qui grimpe
lorsqu'on voit une hausse de vos profits
une hausse dans une certaine mesure de
la rémunération de la direction aussi il
y a même des analyses et des
journalistes qui ont évoqué aujourd'hui
un certain malaise on a ramené le terme
mal-aimé l'avarice flasi comment vous
réagissez à ce malaise là je trouve que
c'est pas juste je pense pas que c'est
une vérité puis je pense pas que c'est
basé sur des faits ce sont ce sont des
commentaires ce sont des opinions tout
le monde a droit à son opinion on va la
respecter c'est sûr que la compagnie a
fait des profits qui sont en fonction
des hausses de vente qu'on fait mais
comme je vous dis nos marges
bénéficiaires n'ont pas augmenté et la
margeonnette est très stable au fil des
ans alors oui il y a une augmentation de
vente il y a une augmentation des
dépenses aussi les salaires sont en
hausse les coût de transport est en
hausse toute la structure est en hausse
on a une scène gestion on a pu absorber
la baisse de l'atmarche bénéficiaire
brut a été absorbé ou compensé par un
bon le rôle des dépenses puis avec la
hausse des ventes on était en mesure de
garder nos bénéfices stages et là tout
le monde essaie de se refiler la facture
monsieur la flèche les fournisseurs
essaient de vouloir filer dans une
certaine mesure vous essayez de passer
sur consommateur mais comme vous le
mentionnez dans un environnement
concurrentiel c'est pas toujours évident
est-ce que vos relations avec vos
fournisseurs sont quand même cordiales
dans le contexte actuel oui elles sont
professionnelles c'est comme je l'ai dit
c'est une réalité mondiale on ne jette
pas le blanc sur les fournisseurs
gratuitement là ils sont ils sont prêts
avec une situation de leur côté aussi et
ils ont des augmentations et ils
cherchent à obtenir des augmentations
alors c'est à nous de le contrôler le
plus possible de les faire justifier le
plus possible et s'assurer que ce soit
des augmentations qui s'appliquent à
tout le monde et après ça nous c'est à
nous de gérer l'augmentation des prix de
détails qu'on peut tout le monde est-ce
que les fournisseurs aussi devraient
mettre un peu d'eau dans leur vin oui il
faut travailler ensemble pour trouver
des solutions la crise du coût de la vie
elle est réelle on le sait très bien on
sait que les consommateurs sont affectés
par l'inflation ça a monté rapidement ça
a monté beaucoup
personne se réjouit de ça ça affecte
comme je le dis tous les congenda ça
fait que nos employés ça affecte nos
gestionnaires c'est une situation
difficile pour tout le monde on espère
que ça va ça va se réduire que
l'inflation va réduire dans les
prochains mois mais force est constaté
que il y a encore de la pression dans le
système et on espère que les événements
mondiaux vont se résorber pour que la la
chaîne d'approvisionnement du côté
d'alimentation soit moins sous pression
mais on contrôle poste non non
clairement c'est sûr que c'est un
contexte qui est favorable et on le voit
partout dans le monde ça pour les
enseignes au rabais si vous voulez
est-ce que par exemple chez Métro on
pourrait mettre l'accent davantage sur
Super C ou les autres manières à bas
prix ailleurs au Canada pénétration elle
est dans toutes les bannières c'est sûr
que quand l'inflation est plus forte les
gens qui peuvent être portés à aller
vers les bannières d'escompte on le voit
depuis quelques trimestres on est bien
positionné chez Métro avec supercés au
Québec faut baisser que c'est un Ontario
mais nous bannière métro conventionnel
aussi offre une excellente valeur on a
des formations hebdomadaires agressives
la gamme de marque privée complète dans
toutes nos bannières même chose si Jean
Coutu et Brunet alors on s'efforce le
plus possible d'offrir la meilleure
valeur possible à nos clients dans
l'ensemble de nos Bagnères c'est un
effort de tous les jours puis je
voudrais juste préciser que l'inflation
alimentaire au Canada elle est elle est
forte elle est regrettable difficile à
accepter mais elle est moindre que dans
la plupart des pays occidentaux humains
elle est moins de cause aux États-Unis
quand France qu'en Angleterre alors on
fait quand même malgré une devise qui
est qui est plus faible ça ça met de la
pression aussi au niveau des prix
coûtants on sentir quand même assez bien
mais le problème avec l'alimentation
monsieur la flèche c'est qu'on est
captif on peut se priver de beaucoup de
choses dans la vie mais on peut pas se
priver de manger il y a des gens qui
vont que ce soit chez vous ou ailleurs à
l'épicerie qui doit faire des compromis
sur la qualité parfois sur la quantité
il y a plusieurs grands groupes là comme
le vôtre qui ont participé à cette
enquête du Bureau de la concurrence là
qui veut réfléchir à des façons
d'augmenter la compétition en ce moment
notamment dans l'industrie comment
comment vous vous accueillez cette
démarche du Bureau de la concurrence on
l'accueille favorablement ce n'est pas
une enquête c'est une étude du haut de
la concurrence sur l'inflation
alimentaire et les causes sous-jacentes
alors il y a eu de la pression des
policiers les participants ont adopté
une résolution en chambre le Bureau de
la concurrence va lancer une étude c'est
pas une enquête alors on va participer
de très volontairement à ça donc
coopérer complètement avec les autorités
de ce côté-là monsieur la flèche merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec ça m'a fait
plaisir merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]